Welcome students to
the Pharmacology of
General Anesthetics,
Dr. Goldstein speaking.
This lecture entails
the inhaled anesthetics,
the intravenous
anesthetics, and
the various
intravenous drugs that
are used in
anesthesia techniques.
Please contact
me if you'd like
to talk about
pharmacology.
The learning objectives
are basically
a guide to what
it is you need
to know about this
group of drugs.
I will be taking
time to explain
them because
the concepts may
be unfamiliar
to many of you.
The materials.
Only the practice
questions are
required. Nothing
else is required.
You can learn
about anesthetics
by any method that
works for you.
The practice questions
will help you assess
your knowledge and to
apply it in context.
Here are some resources
if you wish to
use them. The review
books have practice
questions, and of
course, ScholarRx,
Brex, have practice
questions as well.
Terminology is how
we understand things.
We understand what
the words mean,
the terms mean, and
we can understand
the concepts. So,
my recommendation,
my strong recommendation,
is to look at these,
look at the terminology,
understand the
terminology before
listening to this
video. I also recommend
always to look over
the PowerPoint before
you watch the video.
It will give you an
idea of what's being
covered, the flow, the
concepts, so that when
you actually watch
the video, you already
have in mind what
it's going to be
talking about. and maybe
you've even asked
yourself some questions
and you're ready to
hear the answers.
So I'm not going to
to read all of this
to you. Please take
the time to do that.
And the key points
also is to give you an
overview. You can look
at it or not look at
it. You can use it as
a self-assessment to
discover how well you
understand the learning.
I will not read this
to you either. This
is just for you if
you wish to use it.
So you can see there's
quite a bit to
cover today.
And And so we begin.
General anesthesia
induces a
physiologic state
that typically
includes
analgesia, amnesia,
loss of consciousness,
inhibition of sensory
and autonomic
reflexes, and skeletal
muscle relaxation. The
currently used general
anesthetics do not
provide all of this.
Therefore,
other drugs are
used alongside
it, adjuncts.
Balanced anesthesia
technique is a modern
anesthesia technique
that typically involves
a combination of
intravenous and inhaled
drugs to cause the
depression of the CNS.
what is the advantage
well additive and very
often synergistic
effects of of the
different drugs that are
put together will allow
lower doses of each
of the agents and
what have we remembered
from the lower lowering
of doses is we reduce
at least theoretically
the potential for
adverse effects. Of
course, these drugs are
potentially dangerous
and should be handled
only by people
who are trained and
qualified in their use.
And I've given some
examples here and
I've mentioned some
other anesthesia
techniques that I'll
mention again later.
The two types that
we'll be looking at
are the inhaled
anesthetics which are
gases that are inhaled
by the patient.
Volatile anesthetics
are actually
liquids at room
temperature and then they
are at room
temperature and ambient
pressure and they
are volatilized so
the patient will
breathe in the gas.
And then gases
themselves, nitrous oxide
is the only one we
use is already a gas
and the patient
breathes in that gas.
The IV anesthetics are
lipid-soluble drugs
that preferentially
partition into the
highly perfused
lipophilic tissues. In
other words, they're
lipid-soluble, they
go straight to the
brain, which is a highly
perfused brain and
spinal cord, and
that will produce a
rapid onset of action.
They also redistribute
out of the CNS. They
go into our peripheral
tissues, and if it's
one dose that's given,
the drug will partition
out of the CNS, and
the patient will
emerge from anesthesia.
And we'll talk about
context-dependent half
times for repeated doses
of intravenous
anesthetics. That's later.
The phases of
general anesthesia
are induction.
So the patient
has not received
any anesthesia.
The anesthesia is
administered and the
anesthetic effect is
induced. So that's
the induction phase.
Maintenance days
is to keep that
anesthesia level in
equilibrium throughout
the procedure, throughout
the surgery, to
maintain that surgical
anesthesia. And
then when the drug
is withdrawn, the
patient will recover.
You do not have to
memorize this, these
two charts. They're
here to get you
into the context of
what we're talking
about, the stages of
anesthetic depths.
Stage 1, where
the patient is
being introduced
to the anesthetic.
Stage 2 is a
delirium stage.
The point of anesthesia
techniques is to
bypass that delirium
stage and go to stage 3.
notice stage four
is the organ systems
are shutting down
cardiovascular system
respiratory system
medullary depression
you do need to know
the goals goals for
induction of anesthesia
are to rapidly
and pleasantly produce
hypnosis, amnesia,
analgesia, low
movement, akinesia, and
the autonomic and
sensory block while
maintaining oxygenation,
ventilation,
and hemodynamic
stability. Please
remember this goal of
induction, maintaining
the oxygenation
and hemodynamic
stability. So that's
phase stage three.
The goals for
maintenance are
obviously to maintain
the patient under
anesthesia during
the procedure.
Simple goals.
You know these
intuitively.
Mechanisms.
Well, this has
been a subject of
debate for many,
many years, decades,
hundreds of years
since anesthesia
was first noticed
and used. The
proposed mechanisms
of action that are
based on studies
have identified
molecular targets,
actually proteins,
that are affected
by the various
anesthetics. We
have presynaptic and
postsynaptic, which is
what these figures on
the left hand side
are demonstrating.
The inhaled
anesthetics, with
the exception of
nitrous oxide,
likely diminish the
excitatory activity
and enhance the
inhibitory activity.
Makes sense.
Nitrous oxide is a
mechanism of action has
been identified as
non-competitive NMDA
antagonists. I put
that on the side here.
The molecular targets
is what you are
learning about since
the beginning of the
year and continuing
through this term.
So you should be aware
of the inhibitory
and excitatory
molecular targets and I
will be mentioning
these as we go along.
The inhaled
anesthetics in common
use are these
four isoflurane,
desflurane, seboflurane,
nitrous oxide.
Halothane, even
though it's not
in common use,
has a star on it
because it is
board relevant.
There are certain
features about it that
the board that you can
find on board questions
and I want to make
you aware of them.
N-flurane has not
started. It has
been withdrawn
from the market.
You may see the N
-flurane mentioned in
your board review
studying when you get to
it, but I'm not going
to go over it now.
It's mainly about
its detrimental
properties. it's
maybe I should
say unfavorable
properties.
The gases are nitrous
oxide and xenon.
Xenon is a noble gas and
it's actually considered
an ideal anesthetic.
It doesn't have
a star on it but I
will mention it later.
The volatile anesthetics
are halogenated.
We see halothane with the
fluoride, the bromide,
the chloride,
several fluorine
is only fluoride,
isoflurane is almost all
fluoride but a chloride,
desflurane is all
fluoride. So these are
the halogens and
they are called
halogenated anesthetics
and they are stored
in bottles because
they're liquids at
sea level and the
standard temperatures.
So we call those
volatile anesthetics.
Some properties. I
have highlighted in
colors, different
properties here. So let's
take a look at the
blood gas partition
coefficient. This is
a key concept to know.
Nitrous oxide
has a low one,
desflurane has
a pretty similar
to nitrous oxide,
several fluorine
is low a little
bit higher.
Isoflurane is higher
still. Here is
halothane with
considerably higher still.
I'll be talking
about this partition
coefficient in
terms of solubility.
So a low blood
gas gas partition
coefficient has low
solubility, meaning
the gas has low
solubility in blood.
This is the key concept.
Halothane has a
considerably higher
blood gas partition
coefficient, so it
is considerably more
soluble in blood.
I will explain that
in a few slides.
There are tissue
solubility blood partition
coefficients. This
is for the brain
blood. the tendency
of the gas to dissolve
in the brain tissue.
There are also muscle
and blood tissue
partition coefficients,
fat blood. I didn't
list those here but the
concept is the same.
It's the tendency of
the anesthetic to
dissolve in that tissue.
Now, this feature,
the MAC, we
will talk about
in a future slide,
is a measure
of potency. The
point I want to make
here is that there
are differences in the
potency of these drugs
and that's going to
be related to dosing.
That concept you are
familiar with, we
talked about that in
the foundations course
and so when we get
to this slide you'll
be able to understand
that fairly well.
Metabolism, we'll
talk about that.
Nitrous oxide
is an incomplete
anesthetic. It
is low potency
and a weak anesthetic.
We'll use all
those terms.
The others are potent.
And So this is
the effect on
the airway when
the agent is being
breathed in by
the patient.
There are two that
are not pungent.
You need to know
this, and I will
expand on this
concept later.
And you need to know the
ones that are pungent.
pungent means they
cause airway irritation
an airway irritation
can cause the
patient to hold their
breath to cough it can
cause bronchospasm
laryngospasm so if the
patient is going
to be coughing and
getting bronchospasm
obviously it's not a
good drug to induce
the anesthesia effect.
Those are the takeaways.
All right let's talk
about pharmacokinetics.
Pharmacokinetics of the
inhaled anesthetics
is the key
pharmacokinetic concept
to understanding
the use of
these this drug.
What are we looking at.
Equilibrium. Through
everything we talk
about regarding the
inhaled anesthetics,
please remember the
concept of equilibrium.
Equilibrium is
another term for
steady state. This
is a concept with
which you are very
familiar by now.
So, when the partial
pressure, so let's
talk about partial
pressure for a moment.
This is concentration.
Partial pressure is related
to the concentration
of the anesthetic
gas. It's a gas, so
we talk about the
pressure, the fractional
pressure of this gas
in the various tissues.
In the inspired
air, in the
alveolar air, in
the blood, in the
brain, in the
spinal cord, etc.
The partial
pressure is related
to the concentration
of the drug.
Okay,
so thinking
partial pressure,
thinking concentration.
When the partial
pressure of the
anesthetic gas in
the inspired air, the
alveoli, and the
arterial blood, and the
CNS are in equilibrium,
that's when
we're going to see
the clinical effect.
Equilibrium ensures
that the anesthetic
concentration in the
CNS is stable and
effective for
maintaining anesthesia
during the procedure.
That's the point.
Equilibrium.
Equilibrium is the
key pharmacokinetic
concept around which
all of the rest
of what we'll talk
about revolves.
This is a general
idea here now. Now,
anesthetic uptake
into the blood is
determined by the
pharmacokinetic
characteristics of each
anesthetic agent as
well, as always,
as patient factors.
Pharmacokinetic
characteristics.
Gases move from one
body compartment to
another down their partial
pressure gradients.
Inhaled anesthetics are
taken up through gas
exchange. I have a
picture here of alveoli.
The inspired air goes
into the alveoli, so
we have alveolar air,
and whatever gases are
in that air that make
up each of the different
fractions of gases
in the alveolar air.
this little alveolus
shows the pulmonary
circulation the capillary
network around the
alveolus and this is
where gas exchange
happens we think about
gas exchange in terms
of cardio carbon dioxide
being removed from
blood oxygen being
placed into blood and
we're going to be talking
about the anesthetics
now going into the
blood coming out of
the blood after the
anesthetic is withdrawn.
So inhaled anesthetics
are taken up through
gas exchange between
the alveoli of
the lung and the
pulmonary circulation and
from the pulmonary
circulation the blood
goes back to the
heart and gets pushed
out into the aorta and
arteries and circulates
through the blood,
through the body,
to the different
body compartments.
Simple idea.
Blood goes in,
sorry, gas goes in
and circulates, gets
to the brain, gets
to the other tissues.
Four factors
influencing the uptake.
So now this drug
has, these gases have
to be taken up into
the blood from the
alveoli, from the
alveolar air, in
order to be distributed
throughout. So
we're going to be
talking about uptake
from the alveolar
air into the blood.
And that is going
to be related to
the speed of
anesthetic induction,
inducing that
anesthetic effect in
the patient. So
here are the four.
Well, how much
gas is the patient
breathing in? The
inspired concentration.
The solubility of
the gas in the blood.
I mentioned before
that that is related
to the blood gas
partition coefficient.
with a low blood
gas partition
coefficient indicating
a low solubility of
the gas in the blood
and vice versa.
Of course,
the rate of induction,
the speed of
induction is going
to depend on the
cardiac output. How
much is that heart,
how much blood is
the heart pumping
out in a defined
time per minute?
And the alveolar
venous partial
pressure
difference, which
I'll explain
when I get there.
The speed of
anesthetic exchange
between lungs and
blood is the crucial
factor in
determining the speed
of onset of the
anesthesia. Well,
let's first talk
about the inspired
concentration of the
anesthetic and its uptake in
the blood and the
pulmonary circulation.
So this concept here,
the F-A to F-I ratio,
something you
must understand.
This is all about
equilibrium.
FA is the
concentration of
the fractional
concentration,
so the fraction
of the gas in the
inspired air that's
in the alveoli.
Concentration of
gas in the alveoli.
Fi is the
concentration that the
patient is
breathing in. The FA
to FI ratio,
when it equals 1,
means that the drug
is in equilibrium.
So the FA to
FI ratio is the
driving force for uptake.
And the ratio
is between the
inspired
concentration and the
alveolar concentration.
That's it.
Alveolar partial pressure
determines, so how
much of that gas,
what's the concentration
of the anesthetic
gas in the alveolar
air, determines
how much of the
anesthetic gas will
dissolve in the blood,
well of course that's
going to depend
on the concentration
that's delivered
to the patients in
the inspired gas,
the higher the partial
pressure in the
alveolus, the higher
the partial pressure
in the blood. Obviously,
greater concentration
in the alveoli,
there's going to
be a greater concentration
in the blood.
When steady state
is reached, remember
steady state is
the equilibrium,
the partial pressures
of gas in the inspired
air is approximately
equal to alveolar
error, to the
arterial blood, to the
brain, and now we get
the clinical effect.
So equilibrium,
or you'll see it
referred to as
approaching
equilibrium. Let's
take a look at
this figure now.
Here is the
anesthesia machine
with our volatile
anesthetic in it.
and the gas coming
out of their
canisters is called
a fresh gas flow.
That goes into the
breathing circuit and
it goes into the
lungs. Of course, the
patient is breathing
in and out, comes out
of the lung, goes out,
and it goes around
and around and around.
so when the the
amount of fresh gas flow
is going to determine
the amount that's
inspired that's going
to determine the
amount in the alveoli
and here we have the
interface the pulmonary
capillaries to the
alveoli and the
drug is going down the
concentration gradient
into the pulmonary
circulation and into
the arterial blood
and into the brain.
And then it's also
going to go to the
venous blood and it's
also going to go out
of the brain and into
the venous blood.
And
it's in this blue
color here because the
concentration of drug
now in the venous
blood is lower than
in the arterial blood.
That's the
basic idea here.
Another concept. The
faster the uptake of
anesthetic agent, the
greater the difference
between the inspired and
alveolar concentrations,
and the slower the
rate of induction.
This is all about
equilibrium, rate of
induction, clinical
effect. So why is this
happening? Faster
uptake, slower rate.
Alveolar concentrations
lag behind the
inspired concentrations,
and that's expressed
this way. alveolar
concentrations
are lower than the
inspired, because the
anesthetics are taken
up by the pulmonary
circulation during
this initial phase.
The gas goes into the
breathing circuit,
goes into the lungs, goes
down the concentration
gradient, into
the blood. So the
amount that's in the
alveoli is going to be
lower because it's
it's moving out than
what is coming in
through the inspired air.
When uptake is
rapid, a fast uptake,
a large amount of
anesthetic is absorbed
into the blood
from the alveoli.
Which means, now keep
and remember to think
about equilibrium, the
rapid uptake creates
a significant difference
between the inspired
concentration and the
alveolar concentration
as the alveoli are
depleted faster than
they can be replenished
by the inspired air.
And that's what I
described before.
Remember for the
clinical effect
to occur this
has to equal one
where these two
values are equal.
Speed of induction.
Anesthesia induction
depends on the
equilibrium between
the alveolar and
CNS concentrations.
When uptake is
high, it takes
longer to reach
equilibrium.
Follow me?
If you want you
can stop the video
and kind of review
this if you want
to think about
it a little more.
well ventilation now
the anesthesiologist
can is the one who
controls the amount of the
gas that's being
inspired by the patient
increasing the alveolar
ventilation continuously
replaces the
anesthetic taken up by
the pulmonary bloodstream
and that's going to
provide better maintenance
of that alveolar
concentration as it's
being replenished.
By increasing the
ventilation, the
anesthesiologist can
increase the rate
of induction,
bringing in more gas,
increasing the
rate and depth of
breathing, that's
what ventilation is,
delivers more fresh
gas to the alveoli
per unit of time.
So what are we
talking about?
Speed of induction.
Increasing the
partial pressure, so
increasing the concentration
of the anesthetic
in the alveoli creates
a steeper gradient,
makes sense, right?
Which leads to faster
equilibration with
the arterial blood
because we're sending
more of the gas in.
The partial pressure
of anesthetic in
the brain required to
produce the clinical
effect is therefore
achieved more
quickly, increases the
speed of induction.
So let's talk about
solubility now.
Why is the speed
of induction slower
with the more soluble
anesthetic gases?
The figures on the
right-hand side are
typically shown in a
variety of textbooks.
So let's see if we
can figure this out.
So the concepts
are the more
soluble the anesthetic
is in blood,
the greater the capacity
of the blood for
taking up the anesthetic,
In other words,
more gas is required,
and that's going to
take longer to achieve
that equilibrium,
and therefore
induction will be
slower, and then
the opposite
is true with the
less soluble.
In this figure here,
these larger spheres
compared to these little
spheres indicate that
this anesthetic gas
is very insoluble.
Nitrous oxide is the
prototype here for this.
The very soluble
prototype is halothane.
Now remember,
what is the point?
How do we get to
that induction
point? Well, equilibrium.
So this is the
amount that's being
inspired, and in
the blood and brain,
we need to get
up to this point
in order to achieve
the equilibrium.
FI, FA to FI ratio
equals 1, equilibrium.
So that's the goal.
We see on this figure
that it's pretty close,
nitrous oxide is pretty
close to equilibrium
already because it
doesn't dissolve much
in the blood. And
compared to halothane,
well, gosh, we have a
big difference here.
It's going to take
much longer to
achieve the same
concentration in
the alveoli, in
the arterial blood,
and in the brain
with halothane.
And this is
another way to
show it, this
figure here.
Nitrous oxide, halothane,
nitrous oxide fast,
halothane slow.
The difference in
blood gas partial
pressures, partition
coefficients, sorry,
is a difference
of about 35 times.
Halothane is
much, much, much
more soluble than
nitrous oxide.
Let's talk now
about cardiac output
and the difference
between the alveolar
and venous blood
partial pressures.
So cardiac output first.
Alright,
now think about
cardiac output. Cardiac
output is the amount
of blood that the
heart, that the
ventricles are pushing
into the circulation
per unit of time.
So, if that
cardiac output goes
down, that's going
to reduce the
pulmonary blood
flow, clearly.
It will reduce the
volume going into
the pulmonary
circulation and the speed
at which it goes
into the circulation.
Therefore,
the gas in the alveolar
air is going to
have more time to
move into the blood.
The partial pressure
in blood rises more
quickly when cardiac
output is reduced.
And therefore, that will
increase the speed
of induction.
That is more
pronounced with the
insoluble agents because
they don't dissolve
in the blood as
readily as we see
with the soluble ones.
Now, the opposite
is true when cardiac
output goes up.
Increasing cardiac
output is going
to increase
pulmonary blood flow.
That means there's
a greater amount of
blood going through the
pulmonary circulation,
and it's going at a
faster rate. So the
partial pressure
in blood rises at a
slower rate, more blood
moving faster, and
the speed of onset
is reduced. And, of
course, this would be
more pronounced with
soluble agents because
if there's more blood,
it's just going to
take longer for them
to reach that
equilibrium point that's
necessary to produce
the clinical effect.
Now, looking at the
alveolar venous blood
concentration difference
in relation to the
uptake of the anesthetic
into the blood.
Tissue uptake from
arterial blood
reduces the
partial pressure of
the anesthetic in
the venous blood.
The blood comes
out of the left
ventricle, is pushed
into the aorta, which
moves into the
arterial circulation.
The highly perfused
organs, highly
perfused tissues
will take up the
blood, will move
that anesthetic.
Now let me start over.
Because certain
tissues like the
brain, the CNS, the
spinal cord, brain
and spinal cord,
are highly perfused,
they will get
this drug first.
Meanwhile, the
anesthetic is moving
throughout the body and
the tissues are taking
up the anesthetic
and therefore when
the blood returns
to the heart through
the venous system,
the concentration of
the anesthetic in
the veins is going to
be lower than when
it's in the arteries.
that's here venous
circulation returns
to pulmonary circulation
with little or
no dissolved anesthetic
gas and this is
going to generate
the partial pressure
difference between
the alveolar hair and
the pulmonary circulation
if that difference
is large that That
indicates that
the tissue uptake must
be also very high.
The greater the
difference in gas
concentration, which
we talked about before,
the longer the
time to achieve
equilibrium in
the brain tissue,
so longer time
to induction.
Anesthetic transfer
from the blood to the
neural and non-neural
tissues, so that's
all of the body
tissues, is determined
by the solubility of
the anesthetic in the
tissue, the blood
flow to the tissue,
highly perfused,
moderately perfused, low
perfused, and the
difference in the
concentration, the
partial pressure gradient
between the arterial
blood and the tissue.
I have a picture of
that here. We see this
figure again where I
wanted to demonstrate
that the venous
blood has very little
anesthetic in it
compared to the arterial
blood. A big difference
between them.
Anesthetic gas diffuses
from arterial blood
to tissues. Venous
blood returning to
the alveoli is depleted
of anesthetic, more
gas moves from the
lungs into the blood.
The greater
the difference,
the longer the
time to achieve
equilibrium and
brain tissue.
And this is displayed
graphically.
On the x axis, we
have time in minutes.
On the y-axis, we
have the FA to FI
ratio, with one up
here being equilibrium.
Halothane, we remember,
is highly soluble.
Nitrous oxide is
highly insoluble.
this point here
the patient hasn't
received any anesthetic
gas so the inspired
gas is going right
into the alveoli so
we get this big steep
curve and then it
levels off the
nitrous oxide achieves
approaches equilibrium
much faster than
halothane does. It's
way far away from
equilibrium at this
point, 30 minutes.
Isoflurane does
better. This
actually has a
medium onset.
Sevolflurane
and desflurane
are considered
rapid onset. We
see they're approaching
equilibrium rapidly
and that's why.
Looking at the lower
figure, this shows
tissue distribution.
Again, we have a rapid
steep curve here as the
patient is initially
breathing in
anesthetic. Goes to the
vessel-rich group,
the brain, spinal
cord, other well
-perfused organs, and as
time goes by it drops
off quickly from
those as it is entering
the less well-perfused
tissues, muscle
group in this case,
fat group in this case.
You do not need
to memorize these
numbers. They're here
to give you context.
The concepts that
you do need to
know are that the
vessel-rich group,
and I've indicated
that here,
are the first to
receive the anesthetic
and the first to
approach study state.
This tissue, the CNS
tissue, the highly
perfused tissue,
tends to have a small
volume of a small
capacity to take
up the drug compared
to muscle and fat.
So muscle is less
perfused so the uptake
is slower, but think
about how much muscle
is on our bodies it
has a much greater
capacity to take up
drug and it's going to
do that over time now
fat is the perfusion
is pretty similar to
the muscle however
the drug lipophilic
drug loves lipid is
going is very soluble
in the fat in our
adipocytes and that's
going to take that's
a large capacity and
it's going to take a
long time to approach
steady state in those
tissues so for the
average procedure the
drug is not going
to fill up that fat
reservoir but for
longer procedures it can
Oops, sorry, pushed
the wrong button.
And then the
vassal pore group,
that's the bones,
teeth, et cetera.
Really doesn't
take up much drug.
Let's check knowledge.
I invite you to
stop the video and
look at the next
two slides and see
if you can answer
the questions.
Okay,
what is the fundamental
concept that
ensures the anesthetic
concentration in
the CNS is stable
and effective for
maintaining anesthesia
during the procedure?
When the partial pressure
of the anesthetic
gas in the inspired
air, alveoli, arterial
blood, and CNS are
in equilibrium, which
is defined as F-A or F
-I ratio equals 1, the
desired clinical effect
will be produced.
What four
factors influence
the uptake of anesthesia?
The amount of
drug that's coming
in through the
inspired air,
the solubility of
the gas in the blood,
and the cardiac output
and the difference
in the concentration
of anesthetic
gas between the
arteries and the veins.
Why does the faster
uptake of anesthetic
agent lead to a slower
speed of induction?
When uptake is fast,
a large amount of
anesthetic is absorbed
into the blood from
the alveoli. this
creates a significant
difference between the
inspired concentration
and the alveolar
concentration expressed
as the FA is less
than the Fi as the
alveoli are depleted
of anesthetic faster
than they can be
replenished by inhalation.
So it takes longer
to reach equilibrium.
Why is the speed
of induction slower
with more soluble
anesthetic gases?
The more soluble
the anesthetic
is in the blood,
which is a
higher partition
coefficient,
blood gas partition
coefficient, the greater
the capacity for uptake
into the blood, the
slower the rate of rise
in partial pressure,
the longer it takes
to reach equilibrium.
How does an increase
in cardiac output
lead to a slower
speed of induction?
Increased cardiac
output will increase the
volume and the rate of
pulmonary blood flow.
The partial pressure
of the gas in the blood
is therefore going
to rise more slowly
because there's more
blood to dissolve in and
that will cause a slower
rise towards equilibrium
and therefore a
slower speed of onset.
In this case the effect
is more pronounced
with the soluble
agents which achieve
equilibrium more slowly
in the first place.
How does a large
alveolar tube
venous partial
pressure difference
influence the
speed of induction.
Anesthetic gas is taken
up from the arterial
blood into the non
-neural tissues and
that will reduce the
venous circulation as
I should say the
concentration in the
venous circulation
as it returns to the
pulmonary circulation with
little or no dissolved
anesthetic gas and
that's going to
generate a partial
pressure difference between
the alveolar gas
and pulmonary blood.
The greater the
difference, the
longer the
time to achieve
equilibrium with
the brain tissue.
Recovery is just
the reverse.
That's it.
The longer the
exposure, the
greater the tissue
saturation, the
longer the time
for the patient to
emerge from
anesthesia, and the
longer the
elimination time.
The anesthetic circuit
volume, I haven't
mentioned that before,
but there is gas in
that circuit. The
lower the anesthetic
circuit volume, the
faster the elimination of
the inhaled anesthetic.
Only makes sense.
now elimination they
go out the way they
come in through the
lungs now some drugs have
a well most drugs have
some level of hepatic
metabolism the older
drugs these are not
used methoxyflurane
is super super soluble
and its utility was gone
long long ago but it
was one of the early
inhaled anesthetics.
These three drugs are no
longer in use in the US.
It's these drugs
that I put the
information on
because we use them.
So sevoflurane,
about 5% of it
actually undergoes
hepatic metabolism.
It's the CYP2E1
that mainly
handles these
lipophilic drugs, these
lipophilic
halogenated drugs.
Isoflurane, next.
Disflurane, very little.
And nitrous oxide, really
virtually no
hepatic metabolism.
Let's talk now
about potency.
The minimum alveolar
concentration,
MAC,
is the standardized
standardized
measure of potency.
So what do we use
it for? It helps
us with dosing.
Definition. One MAC is
defined as the alveolar
concentration that
prevents movement in
50% of patients in
response to a pain, a
noxious stimulation, a
standardized stimulus
pain of surgical
incision. So 50 percent.
This is a obviously
a statistical
average. It's a median.
Therefore it's essential
to individualize
therapy because
MAC can be altered
by a number of
different factors.
A number of
different variables
physiologic and
pharmacologic. I'm not
asking you to memorize
the variables.
Just please remember
that MAC is altered
by several things,
and MAC is just a
statistical average.
I will repeat the
definition. The
alveolar concentration,
so the amount of
drug in the alveolar
air that prevents
movement in 50% of
patients in response
to a standardized
pain, pain of surgical
incision stimulus.
Okay, now how does
that relate to potency?
Well,
this is a concept that
you're familiar with.
We know that potency
is really determined
by the amount of
drug at the site
of action that will
produce the effect.
The gas canisters,
and therefore the
amount of drug
that's breathed in,
contain, let me
just back up.
The drug is actually
measured in volume
percent, how much of
the gas coming through
that's being inspired,
how much of it, what
percentage of it is
the anesthetic gas.
With nitrous oxide,
even 100% of nitrous
oxide being breathed
in by the patient
does not produce
full anesthesia.
It is a really non
-potent anesthetic,
a weak anesthetic.
Halothane, less than
one volume percent
is going to produce
one MAC. It's going to
produce, it's going to
prevent the movement
to a pain stimulus
in 50% of patients.
Only less than one
volume percent.
Sevolflurane
is also potent.
Desflurane, 6%, still
considered potent.
Don't need much of the
anesthetic to
produce the effect.
So these are potent,
isoflurane also, and
this one is weak.
Nitrous oxide is weak.
Now, how do we use
that with dosing?
First of all, Now,
by talking about the
potency of the drug
in terms of MAC,
we can therefore
compare the amount of
drug needed to produce
this desired effect.
The usual dosage is a
half to one and a half
max, and different
drugs can be combined
together. So a half MAC
of one drug, frequently
nitrous oxide, can
be combined with a
half MAC of another,
of a potent, volatile
anesthetic, and that's
going to equal one MAC
of anesthetic. And if
that is the desired
concentration to produce
the anesthetic effect
in an individual
patient, there you go.
Potency and dosing.
So, correlation.
And this graph here
will help you to see
the differences in
the potencies of
these drugs. Still
potent, not potent.
MAC provides a
direct correlation
between the
alveolar anesthetic
concentration and the
concentration at the
sites of action in
the CNS potency.
MAC permits
comparison of the
relative anesthetic
potencies of the
different anesthetics.
Very useful.
Always think about
the patient factors.
Individualize
patient care.
I cannot say this
too many times.
Individualize.
You don't have to
memorize these.
Just keep in mind
the concept of
individualization.
the fact that
physiologic as well
as pharmacologic
factors can alter MAC,
alter the dose
that's necessary to
induce anesthesia,
maintain
anesthesia in the
individual patient.
Okay,
effects.
I'm going to spend
quite a bit of
time talking
about the effects.
cardiovascular.
So what are we thinking
about here? I know
you haven't had the
cardiovascular system,
but we're going to
just keep it simple.
We're talking about
the blood vessels
and we know blood
vessels will
constrict, vasoconstriction.
We know blood
vessels will dilate
vasodilation.
Vasoconstriction
increases blood pressure.
Vasodilation decreases
blood pressure.
We also know that the
strength or the force
of myocardial contraction
is what pushes
the blood out of the
ventricles and into,
one, the pulmonary
circulation and, two,
the aorta. So we're
going to be talking
about cardiac output.
Cardiac output is the
amount of blood that
the heart pushes out
in a specific amount
of time per minute.
So that's cardiac output.
When the cardiac output
is reduced, that's
going to cause a lower
blood pressure. When
the cardiac output
increases, that's going
to cause a higher
blood pressure because
there's more blood to
push against the vessels,
and therefore the
blood pressure goes up.
Now we need to talk about
the baroreflex again.
Baroreflex senses
the pressure of
the blood within
the vasculature,
mean arterial pressure.
When the mean arterial
pressure goes up,
the baroreflex is to
activate the parasympathetic
nervous system to
reduce the heart
rate. When the baroreflex
senses low blood
pressure, then the
sympathetic nervous system
becomes disinhibited
and that will increase
the heart rate, even
causing tachycardia,
and constrict the
blood vessels, the
vasculature, to bring
up the blood pressure.
So cardiac output increases
and the vasculature
vasoconstricts
and both together
increase blood pressure.
So that's the baroreflex
that we're going to
be talking about.
So how do these
inhaled anesthetics
affect the various
organ systems? Well,
we see that they're
depressant on
the nervous system
and they're basically
depressant on the
other systems.
However, they have
differences among them.
On this chart,
I'm only talking
about isoflurane,
desflurane,
sevoflurane, and
nitrous oxide,
because they're the
ones that are used.
We'll talk more about
the cardiovascular,
in which I include
halothane again,
because it could
appear on a board exam.
Basically, the inhaled
anesthetics, the
volatile anesthetics
decrease the blood
pressure with little or
no effect on the cardiac
output. I'm talking
about these three.
And they depress
the baroreflex
and I've indicated
to what degree.
Now one other thing
happens. Desflurane
actually caused
sympathetic stimulation.
I'll talk more about
that on the next slide.
Nitrous oxide
has negligible
effects on the
cardiovascular chair,
mainly because
of net effects.
This is the
takeaway though.
So hemodynamic
stability. Think about if
it has low effects on
the cardiovascular,
the cardiovascular
system,
like nitrous oxide, then
there's hemodynamic
stability.
Respiratory. Well,
respiratory
depression mainly.
Decreased tidal
volume, so that's
how much is being
breathed in,
and minute ventilation
over minutes.
decreased ventilatory
response to
carbon dioxide
so when carbon
dioxide levels in
the blood go up
the way we reduce
those is to blow them
off so normally
when carbon dioxide
blood vessels blood
levels go up we breathe
faster we breathe
deeper to blow off
that carbon dioxide
well that response
has been depressed
by the anesthetics,
so the respiratory
center is less sensitive
to noticing elevations
in carbon dioxide.
A good thing is
that they cause
bronchodilation,
especially sevoflurane.
That said, the
drugs that are
pungent, even
though they cause
bronchodilation,
can cause coughing,
breath-holding,
laryngospasm of
the larynx, and
bronchospasm, because
that's the reflex
response to this
airway irritation.
Cevoflurine
doesn't cause that.
Cerebral effects,
well cerebral
depression, the The
vasodilation is going
to increase how much
blood is flowing
through the cerebral
vasculature.
So there's going to be
more blood
flowing through.
And more blood
flowing through means
the pressure
inside the cranium,
which doesn't expand
with that increased
pressure, is going
to be higher.
And as these
are depressants,
CNS depressants,
the cerebral
metabolic rate is
going to go down.
Sevolflurane, we know,
causes bronchodilation,
but it also decreases
the cerebral
blood flow and
the intracranial
pressure to a
lesser extent.
Nitrous oxide increases
all of these things.
Neuromuscular.
Well, these volatile
anesthetics are skeletal
muscle relaxants,
which is a good
thing for surgery.
However, by giving a
neuromuscular blocker,
then we don't need
as much depth of
anesthesia to produce
that skeletal muscle
relaxation, Which
is a good thing,
because we know the
deeper the anesthesia,
the greater the risk
of moving into that
stage 4 and shutting
down the organ systems.
These drugs have a really
narrow therapeutic
window.
nitrous oxide
does not relax
skeletal muscle
or a smooth muscle
and speaking of
smooth muscle
the and the volatile
anesthetics also relax
smooth muscle so we're
thinking about the
vasodilation the
bronchodilation we're
thinking about uterine
smooth muscle relaxation
and when does this
matter in pregnancy.
So at times of labor
and delivery, uterine
smooth muscle relaxation
is not desirable.
Decreased renal blood
flow and that in
turn is going to
decrease the glomerular
filtration rate and
decrease urine output.
So decreasing the whole
renal, the
kidney process.
Decreasing
hepatic blood flow
also and here
I've got the
hepatic metabolism
numbers again.
Don't have to
memorize the these
numbers just
take the concept.
All right let's
talk further
about these
hemodynamic effects.
Depression of
cardiac contractility
will decrease the mean
arterial pressure.
Okay, why?
Depressing cardiac
contractility means
reducing the force of
contraction, which means
less volume of blood
is going to be pushed
out of the heart in a
given amount of time,
which means a decreased
cardiac output.
Alright, how are
these different drugs?
What's the differences
between these drugs?
Halothane and Enflurane,
more myocardial
depression, in
other words, more
depression of this
cardiac contractility.
So that's going to
decrease the cardiac
output. Compared to
others, there's less
vasodilation, so that's
not going to change
the systemic vascular
resistance that much.
Looking at isoflurane,
desflurane, and
sevoflurane, it causes
vasodilation, which
is going to decrease
the blood pressure,
decrease the systemic
vascular resistance,
which decreases
blood pressure. But
there's very little
change in the cardiac
output, which means
that these three drugs
preserve cardiac
output, and between
preserving cardiac output
and the vasodilation,
which decreases the
pressure that the
ventricles have to
push against, and
decreases the preload,
which decreases the
amount of drug coming
back into the heart.
These are considered
preferable effects
compared to halothane
and influrane.
Why?
Isoflurane, desflurane,
and seboflurane
have minimal myocardial
depressant effects.
that's this part,
preserved cardiac output,
and favorable
hemodynamic profiles and
may be suitable for
patients who have impaired
myocardial function.
And what does that
mean? Myocardial
function, that is the
strength of contraction
of the myocardium.
Now desflurane
has another little
feature here that
I briefly referred
to earlier. It
causes a transient
sympathetic
stimulation because
it releases
catecholamines.
Well, sympathetic
stimulation, we're
talking about
catecholamines, correct?
It's the
catecholamines that
produce the
adrenergic effects.
So what's going
to happen?
Heart rate's going
up, tachycardia,
blood pressure's
going up.
These are transient,
that means they last
for a matter of minutes,
several minutes,
especially when
the high doses are
used or the dose has
been increased by
ventilation by the
anesthesiologist.
Tachycardia can
persist. Okay, usually
that's not going to be
much of a problem, but
if a person has
coronary artery disease,
which is plaques,
angina, meaning the
coronary arteries
tend to be occluded
and don't deliver
as much oxygen as
in the non diseased
coronary arteries,
that can lead to
a heart attack. An
ischemic episode
and a heart attack.
So that's a word
of caution with the
desflurane because of that
sympathetic stimulation.
Even though it only
lasts probably less
than 10 minutes, it
can still be a problem
in people with coronary
artery disease.
All right, emergence.
So patients, the
drug has been discontinued
and the patient
will now be emerging
from the anesthetic.
All of these
volatile anesthetics
can cause nausea
and vomiting. It
just is. And nitrous
oxide seems to
have the highest
incidence of it.
They cause nausea
and vomiting because,
after all, they're
going everywhere
and they're basically
a poison. The
body doesn't
recognize these drugs,
recognizes them as
intruders, as poison.
So that's going to
trigger the chemoreceptor
trigger zone and
vomiting center.
nausea and vomiting.
Well this can be
managed fortunately
with antiemetics
and I've listed
some here. You don't
have to memorize
those. Just remember
drugs that prevent
nausea and vomiting.
Avoid nitrous oxide.
Use propofol. Now
this is an intravenous
that happens to
have anti-emetic
properties. We'll be
talking about this one.
And don't use
opioids. Use something
else. Ketorolac
is an NSAID,
non-steroidal anti
-inflammatory drug.
This is the main
one, but there are
different strategies
as you can see.
So a patient's blood
pressure and heart
rate are going to go
up. They're coming
out of this traumatic
episode they've
been through, even
though they've been
anesthetized. And
they're also going to
be likely in pain,
and that's going to
increase hypertension
and tachycardia.
And it just so
happens that there is
post-anesthesia
shivering. The ORs tend to
be cold, the body
cavity has been
opened, and possibly
the IV fluids that are
being used are cold,
and so that core
temperature goes
down, patients shiver.
And emergence
excitement, tachycardia,
restlessness, crying,
moaning, thrashing,
and the neurologic
signs have also
been temporarily
altered, so we can see
differences in our
neurologic signs.
Okay, toxicity.
This is just a little
chart to help you
see which ones
tend to be, which
toxicities the individual
drugs will show.
Malignant hyperthermia,
the takeaway here
is the halogenated
drugs, not nitrous oxide.
They all have a very
narrow therapeutic
window, this is low
therapeutic index.
Hepatotoxicity,
this is the reason
I've included
halothane here.
I've seen this on
board exams, I've
seen this in board
review questions,
and it's an
important concept.
Sevolflurane produces
this product here
that's been given
the name Compound A,
which has been
theorized to cause
nephrotoxicity. It
hasn't been seen in
humans, but it has
been seen in animals.
and fluorine as far
as I'm concerned
you don't have to
look at that one now
b12 deficiency here
we have nitrous
oxide vitamin b12 and
anemia environmental
toxicity every
single one of them
These drugs, these
inhaled anesthetics,
are vented into the
outside environment.
Now I have descriptions
here. The other
was just a chart to
help you organize them.
The acute toxicities,
because of the narrow
therapeutic range,
organ damage is low,
when it's used by
trained people but it can
be high if it's used
by people who have not
been are not qualified
to use these drugs.
Malignant hyperthermia,
this is related
to people who have
genetic disorders of
skeletal muscle which
may not be obvious.
They can develop
the rigidity,
hyperthermia,
tachycardia,
hypercapnia,
that's elevated
carbon dioxide levels,
elevated potassium
levels, and metabolic
acidosis. We talked
about it with
succinylcholine.
It also happens with
the halogenated,
which are the
volatile anesthetics.
Nitrous oxide
does not cause it.
We talked about
nephrotoxicity
before. hepatotoxicity.
Hepatic dysfunction
following surgery
and general
anesthesia is most
likely caused by
what the patient is
going through rather
than the drug.
I'll talk about halothane
hepatitis at
a later slide.
Neurotoxicity.
There is this concern
of neurotoxicity
in infants and
young children.
Studies are ongoing.
So far, it's just
not clear what the
neurotoxic effects
are in children. Let's
talk about carbon
monoxide poisoning.
Carbon monoxide,
think about the
breathing circuit. Well,
inside that breathing
circuit is a product
that will remove
carbon dioxide from the
breathing circuit so
that the patient can
reuse the air in that
breathing circuit.
Well, if that product is
dried out, the halogenated
anesthetics can
form carbon monoxide,
which will then be
breathed in by the
patient. Really important
to change that carbon
dioxide absorber so
that there's fresh
the fresh absorber in
there it's not dried out
and here's the potential
for carbon dioxide
carbon monoxide
formation desflurane
is the worst offender
isoflurane and several
fluorine much less so but
it can still cause it
carcinogenicity well
these drugs don't
appear to cause cancer.
Pregnancy.
Pregnant patients are
sometimes going to
have to have surgery,
and the surgery may
require the use of an
inhaled anesthetic.
There appears to be
an increased incidence
in loss of the fetus
with these drugs,
but the reason for
it is not clear. And
then I mentioned the
environment before.
These drugs are
super, super,
super potent
greenhouse gases.
Nitrous oxide has
some other features to
be aware of. So the
ones that we saw before,
all those features.
Now, it can cause
body space volume
expansion. You need to
understand the mechanisms
of these effects.
So nitrous oxide, N2O,
is 35 times
approximately more
soluble in blood
than nitrogen, N2.
Therefore, nitrous
oxide diffuses
into cavities faster
than nitrogen can
diffuse out. So
we're talking about
air-filled cavities
at this point.
So because there
is both nitrous
oxide and nitrogen
in there, that
increases the
volume inside the
cavity, and so the
cavity expands.
However, when
the walls of the
cavity are rigid,
such as in the
eye, such as in
the middle ear.
The pressure will rise
instead of the volume.
Cautions, these
are the cautions.
So people who have
a pneumothorax,
people with
intracranial error,
middle ear surgery,
bowel obstruction.
Nitrous oxide
should be avoided in
these patients
because of this
body space volume
expansion effect.
And just an FYI,
the nitrous oxide
can also diffuse
into the tracheal
tube cuff and
that can increase
the pressure
against the trachea.
Vitamin B12.
Nitrous oxide interferes
with vitamin
B12 functions.
Vitamin B12 is essential
for functions
of methionine.
When vitamin B12
is deficient, that
can cause anemia.
It's called vitamin
B12 megaloblastic
anemia, and megaloblastic
anemia due to vitamin
B12 deficiency
can cause peripheral
neuropathy.
So nitrous oxide
should not be used
for chronic pain
relief because the
patient will be
exposed to this nitrous
oxide repeatedly and
over time. And that
will eventually
reduce the stores of
B12 and lead to
megaloblastic anemia.
The drug should
also be avoided
in patients who
already have B12
deficiency,
folate deficiency,
methionine synthesis, or
metabolism deficiency.
Diffusion hypoxia
now. So when nitrous
oxide is discontinued,
the nitrous oxide
naturally is going
to diffuse out of the
blood back into the
lungs via the alveoli.
The nitrous oxide
will then dilute the
oxygen in the alveoli.
So what do we do?
administer oxygen
and this is done
for a few minutes
before the nitrous
oxide is discontinued
and afterwards.
Now there's something
called a second
gas effect.
When we remember that
nitrous oxide is in
thought fairly is quite
insoluble in blood.
Therefore, it is taken up
rapidly from the alveoli.
It moves into
the blood and
quickly approaches
equilibrium.
Well, contraction
of the alveolar
volume as the
nitrous oxide leaves
concentrates the co
-administered inhaled
drug that's left in
the alveoli. So now we
have more concentration
higher higher
concentration and that's
going to speed induction
this is something
that's always brought up
remember nitrous
oxide isn't used alone
it's used with other
things it produces a
nice smooth induction
um but it's probably
actually insignificant
in clinical practice.
It's still
something that it's
a concept you
need to remember.
Alright, now we're on to
halothene hepatitis.
This is rare.
Halothene is
still used in some
areas of the world.
It's quite cheap.
It is metabolized by
CYP2E1 and it forms
reactive intermediate,
which is unstable,
and I've indicated
right here, and it can
form something called
neoantigen. So it
binds to liver proteins
and it will draw
the immune system.
It's immunogenic. It
will draw the immune
system to attack it.
And the immune system
attack will cause
inflammation and
liver cell damage.
So we have direct
toxicity by
this unstable
intermediate,
and we have this
immune attack.
There are certain
risk factors for this.
For example, previous
exposure to halothane.
It seems to be
higher incidence in
the obese female.
That doesn't mean that
nobody else will
develop this, but that's
the way the population
incidence goes.
And the CO2 absorber,
I've given you a
picture here of the
product and the CO2
absorber within the
breathing circuit.
These are highly
basic, although
the newer ones
are less so.
And when this CO2
absorber is dried
out and the anesthetic,
the halogenated
anesthetic, passes
through it, this
is when carbon
monoxide can be formed.
That's the basic idea.
That's the concept.
And the prevention?
Make sure that
it's fresh.
dust fluorine greater
than n-flurane
which there's I
mean they all still
produce carbon
monoxide dust fluorine
seems to be the
worst culprit though
okay here's xenon
you do not have to
memorize this this
is an example of what
the ideal gas anesthetic
would look like
highly insoluble
inert at room
temperature and standard
pressure doesn't
catch on fire
this one xenon
happens to be a non
-competitive antagonist
of NMDA receptor
and other effects
has minimal side
effects how good is
that no cardiovascular
vascular effects,
respiratory
depression, renal
or hepatic toxicity,
not metabolized,
environmentally safe,
but it is super
expensive because it's
obtained by extracting
it from air.
And it's not
approved in the
U.S. It is
approved elsewhere.
All right, check
your knowledge.
What is the acronym
that MAC stands for?
Minimum alveolar
concentration.
How does it
define potency?
One MAC is the
concentration of inhaled
gas in the alveoli
that prevents
movement in 50% of
patients in response
to a standardized
stimulus at standard
temperature and
ambient pressure.
MAC reflects the
brain partial
pressure and
allows comparisons
of potency
between agents.
So how is it
used in dosing?
Dosing is guided
by MAC and
MAC values are additive.
Which ones are the potent
volatile anesthetics?
Isoflurane, desflurane,
and sevoflurane
are the ones that
are in common use.
And why is nitrous oxide
referred to as a
weak anesthetic?
It has low potency.
Even 100% nitrous
oxide does not
achieve one MAC.
Therefore, it's
combined with a potent
volatile anesthetic.
That's the typical use.
Why may isoflurane,
desflurane, and
sevoflurane be
suitable for patients
with impaired
myocardial function?
because they cause
vasodilation which lowers
systemic vascular
resistance and blood
pressure without a
with minimal change to
cardiac output which
preserves cardiac
output and of course
always we do have to be
monitoring patients
throughout anesthesia
care, and although
desflurane causes
vasodilation with minimal
effect on force of
contraction, myocardial
depressant effects,
its transient
sympathomimetic properties
cause tachycardia and
hypertension, especially
at high dose, and
that can cause, that
can induce cardiac
ischemia and heart attack
in patients with
coronary artery disease.
Which inhaled anesthetics
are associated
with malignant
hyperthermia in
patients with
genetic disorder and
skeletal muscle
calcium regulation?
Allogenated ones, but
not nitrous oxide.
And this is
just a matching.
I invite you to
do this on your
own. The answers
to all of
these questions
are at the end.
I hope you try it
on your own first.
and intravenous
anesthetics. We'll be
able to go through
these pretty quickly.
These are basic concepts,
basic pharmacokinetic
concepts that
you are familiar
with because these
drugs are administered
intravenously and
use milligram doses.
So let's take a look
at their features.
Redistribution is an
important concept with
highly lipophilic
drugs so a single bolus
dose one dose is
administered and it will
go to the highly
perfused tissues first
the CNS and other
highly perfused organs
see this two-way arrow
then as the circulation
goes around again,
makes the circuit,
it will go through
the venous system,
the arterial system,
venous system,
drop off some drug
to the various
compartments, muscle
and fat, and circle back
to the brain at
lower concentrations.
And now
the drug will move
out of the brain
back into the
circulation where it
again goes into
the other tissues,
decreasing the amount
of drug in the brain
tissue. As the drug
concentration in
blood decreases, the
anesthetic begins to
redistribute out of
the CNS to the less
perfused tissues,
diminishing the effect.
The patient emerges
from anesthesia. So
the patient emerges
because the concentration
of drug in the
brain tissue is low
even though the drug
is still in the body.
But eventually the drug
will be eliminated. it.
Now context-sensitive
half-time is the half
-life related, the
plasma half-life related
to the duration of
infusion. So half
-time, you're familiar
with that concept. Time
required for the
concentration of drug
to decrease by 50% after
stopping a continuous
infusion. We're
talking about not one
bolus dose now but a
continuous infusion.
And that amount of
time is going to depend
on how long that drug
has been infused.
So we know the IV
anesthetic initially
distributes to
the well-perfused
tissue and the drug
redistributes to the
less-perfused
tissue. So the longer
the infusion, the
more drug accumulates
in the muscle and
fat compartments.
So after the infusion
is stopped, the
drug will leave the
blood by the usual
elimination methods,
metabolism and
excretion, and that
will mobilize the
drug to move out
of the tissue
compartments and back
into the bloodstream.
drug redistributes
from peripheral
compartments back
into the bloodstream.
For drugs that have been
infused for a
long duration,
the context-sensitive
half-time, so the
amount of time to
decrease by 50% out of the
blood, can be
significantly longer than
we would see with that
same drug in a short
infusion. because of the
extensive accumulation
in the fat and
muscle compartments.
Why do we care?
Context-sensitive
halftime helps predict
how long it will
take the patient to
recover after the
infusion is stopped.
And this chart
will show the
differences in
context-sensitive
halftimes between
the various drugs.
Diazepam, thiopental,
which isn't used
anymore, have these really
long context-sensitive
half-times. They're
highly lipophilic,
and they cling to the
peripheral tissues.
Propofol, etomidate,
ketamine, they're
down here on the
bottom. So their
recovery tends to
be faster with them.
looking at the
mechanisms and the
uses propofol
atomidate and
ketamine which i'm
focusing on here
ketamine is a non
-competitive nmda receptor
antagonist the others
are gaba a receptor
positive allosteric
modulators like the
benzodiazepines like
the barbiturates rapid
anesthesia induction,
rapid sequence intubation,
total intravenous
anesthesia,
especially propofol,
sedative, hypnotic, and
ICU, especially propofol,
monitored anesthesia care
sedation,
especially propofol.
Propofol is really
useful intravenous
anesthetic. It has of
many favorable qualities.
And here they
are. Propofol
causes bronchodilation,
decreases the
cerebral metabolic
rate of oxygen
consumption,
which is measurable.
The cerebral blood flow,
the intracranial
pressure, it is anti
-emetic and anti
-pyritic, prevents
itching and
anticonvulsant properties.
And here are some
problems with it. These
are pretty common we
see with anesthetics,
hypotension,
respiratory depression.
Propofol infusion
syndrome, I've indicated
down here, you should
be familiar with this.
It is rare, but the
anesthesiologist
really has to be alert to
looking for signs
and symptoms.
It's a painful
injection. It's usually
given with an opioid
anyway for anesthesia.
This is an
interesting feature
of the actual
formulation.
It comes in a four
-ounce bottle. It's not
a big amount. So in
certain anesthesia and
certain surgical
procedures, a large number
of these bottles is
going to be necessary
because in order to
emulsify this propofol,
it's in an egg phosphate
and soybean oil
vehicle, which is a
lovely bacterial medium.
and as a result
there is a potent
microbial sorry a
high microbial risk
and also with this
egg stuff and soybean
stuff their
potential allergens.
So once the the bottle
is spiked for the
IV infusion it has to
be used right away.
etomidate hemodynamic
stability so there
are no changes in
blood pressure that's a
big takeaway also it's
really really fast
acting uh and it has anti
-convulsant properties
now this has some
interesting side effects
uh painful i mean
these you can expect
has no analgesic effects.
It causes myoclonus.
This is myoclonus, so
clonus. So this
involuntary muscle
movements, and it's not
related to seizures.
Myoclonus can
sometimes be related to
seizures, but this is
not. And it inhibits this
enzyme called 11-beta
hydroxylase which is
necessary for the
synthesis of cortisol so
it's going to cause
this adrenal suppression
for this short amount
of time that the
atomidate is in the body
which means atomidate
should not be used for
long infusions such
as would be sedation
of the mechanically
ventilated patient
in the ICU so this is
some unique feature that
should be remembered
and this one this is
not serious but it is
a unique feature this
myoclonus now ketamine
has profound analgesic
properties this
is a non-competitive
NMDA inhibitor receptor
inhibitor like nitrous
oxide and both of
them have these great
analgesic properties,
pain inhibition.
Ketamine causes
bronchodilation,
also a nice feature.
Sympathetic stimulation
I have on both sides.
So sympathetic stimulation
can be beneficial
in people who have
hemodynamic instability,
but it can be harmful
in patients who have
hypertension or
coronary artery disease.
So sympathetic
stimulation is
something to remember
here too, and
it can be given
IM if necessary.
This is also
a key feature,
all these are key
features, but this is
a unique feature. It
can cause hallucinations
and delirium,
dissociative
experiences terrible
nightmares and nausea and
vomiting upon
withdrawal of the drug.
And all of these
are drugs you
need to know
for this block.
Dexmedetomidine I
have in here because
it's an alpha 2 agonist
and its features
are like Clonidine,
which was in
block one, which is
why it has a star on
it. You've already
learned about it.
And I've defined here
monitored anesthesia
care. These drugs
are often used in
monitored anesthesia
care, which is IV drugs.
And the patient usually
has no endotracheal
intubation. And so
the anesthesiologist
is just monitoring
the level of sedation.
i've talked about
them here i'm
not going to
go into details
you can see them
for yourself
benzodiazepines is
uh we talked about in
seizures you'll
you'll see them again
and sedative hypnotics
propofol we talked
about ketamine we talked
about dexmedetomidine
is this Alpha-2
-adrenergic agonist,
which is like
clonidine, has the same
effects as clonidine.
It is more sedating,
got good anxiolytic
properties. It has
some analgesic
properties. So these are
important features
of dexmedetomidine.
Slower onset
of sedation, so
they're not great
for the immediate
sedation or
nearly immediate.
Gradycardia, hypotension,
dry mouth, same
as clonidine.
So this is
features of the
alpha-2 receptor agonism,
central, so inhibition of
central sympathetic
actions.
Opioids is part
of this block.
Lidocaine is part of
this block. So you can,
these are just
brief summaries of
the effects you'll
learn more, that
you have learned
or will learn more
about each individual
group of drugs.
And the summary, I'm
not going through this
all with you, I had
this in the beginning.
advantages and
disadvantages,
nitrous oxide,
all of the
various IV agents,
and the answers
to the questions.
So thank you very much.
This had to be a
long video because
there is so much
to tell you about.
Good luck.